hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 22nd of April and you are watching
games but news first up Blizzard want
you to make friends and they're gonna
help you do it with a new hearthstone
centric initiative fireside gatherings
fireside gatherings are essentially
meetups where you can earn a fireside
friends card back for your collection
after playing three matches against a
player on the same network while at
least three people are logged into
hearthstone using that same network Matt
just can be played through your
battlenet friends list or using the
player near me feature as long as those
other two criteria are met get-together
locales can be found on blizzard's
fireside gathering website which include
universities cafes and gaming lounges or
you can host your own if you so choose
uncharted 4 could be a thing that's
happening at e3 this year according to
an industry insider two ducks who has
accurately leaked PlayStation info
before said on Twitter uncharted 4
gameplay at e3 game has been in the
works for almost three years the game
was announced back in November and while
there's a teaser trailer and a lot of
concerning talent dropouts from Naughty
Dog lately that's all the news on the
game we've got at the moment dragon age
inquisition officially has a release
date as announced by Bioware today in a
brand-new trailer october seven will be
the date to keep in mind if you've got
your eye on the RPG when it'll be
launching a cross current and last gen
consoles as well as PC apart from epic
dragons and some old series favorites
making cameos the trailer also reveals
that pre-ordering the game will earn you
the flames of the Inquisition pack no
word on what that's actually going to
include yet though speaking of Awesome
trailers Namco Bandai have released
their offering in the form of law to the
fallen onto the world today and it looks
pretty sweet the Dark Souls publisher
may have made yet another action RPG but
resemblance to the hugely popular
franchise isn't a bad thing and the
game's developers think it stands apart
the trailer depicts a warrior dodging
around a giant armored behemoth of a
creature before finally managing to slay
it the words every Victor
is born from defeat after enough on
screen just before the monster is
finished up so dark souls basically you
should let me know in that commenting
section below whether you're more
excited for dragon age inquisition all
Lords of the Fallen or if you prefer you
can chat to me directly on my Twitter
where I'm at just McDonald and those are
all the things that I wanted to tell you
about today but be sure to join me same
time and place tomorrow for a bunch more
news so I'll see you soon